le calcul leur avaient toujours donné
pas mal de fil à retordre étant donné
qu'il a laissé 4 moore et qu'il ne
pouvait pas compter plus loin que 4 vous
souvenez mais le prouver sur shadow cour
avait réformé tout ça écoutons jean
quand il n'y a pas du chat d'oc ont dit
qu'un et on écrit quand il ya un shadok
de plus son début et on écrit quand il y
en a encore un chat d'oc ont disons et
on écrit et quand il ya encore un autre
on dit me et on écrit tout le monde
applaudissait qu'on peut être mais ça
génial de vaincre les utiliser pour le
poly d'un soult deux enfants des bêtises
pareilles et que j'adore qu'on allait le
condamner civile c'est très applaudi les
mathématiques l'intéressé bien sûr mais
brûler le professeur c'était intéressant
aussi pour dire décidé à l'unanimité
pour le laisser parler et cool brûlerait
après à l'areas réputé avec moi me son
but cas qu'un but so me crie après
décaler le plombier si je mets un shadok
en plus évidemment je n'ai plus assez de
mots pour les croustilles alors c'est
très sain on les gestes dans une
poubelle et je dis que j'ai deux
poubelles et pour ne pas confondre avec
le but du début je dis qu'il n'ya pas de
chat d'oc à côté de la poubelle et
j'écris gars on continue notre jo
poubelles et pas de chat d'oc à côté
comme si je mets un shadok en plus il me
faut une autre poubelle
mais comme je n'ai plus de mots pour
compter des poubelles je m'en débarrasse
en des jetons dans une grande poubelle
j'écris but grande poubelle avec pas de
petites poubelles n'est pas du chat d'oc
à côté bus gas gas et on continue donc
moi quand on arrive là et qu'on a trop
de grandes poubelles pour pouvoir les
compter et bien roulé mais dans une
super poubelle on écrit du gas gas gas
et on continue